welcome to the Deshawn MIDI your host
thank you for tuning in for another
exciting episode of the Deen show women
out there I'm gonna ask you a question
do you want to be desired cherished and
adored by your husbands I know every one
of you probably said yes I do well my
next guest miss Laura Doyle who has been
featured on CBS NBC Today Show Good
Morning America and the view and she is
the New York Times bestselling author
why because over a hundred fifty
thousand plus women credit her not only
to saving their relationships but also
to helping them become desire cherish
and adored
she's also going to be giving us the top
three reasons now get this this will
blow your mind according to her how
traditional behavioral marriage
counseling can destroy your marriage now
I mean for many people that's like a
shock but she's gonna be backing it up
with evidence and according to a UCLA
study most people who go to this kind of
marriage counseling you know has to
constantly night you spend thousands of
dollars and you go once a week and you
just complain about each other back and
forth and then to find out one year
later seventy-five percent of people who
go to this counseling they end up
divorcing anyway according to a UCLA
study by professors of psychology yes
she's going to be giving us those top
three reasons with Laura Doyle here on
the Dean show this is an episode you
don't want to miss you want to save your
marriage you want to become adored
cherished desired by your husband she's
going to be giving you the natural
aphrodisiac when we come back here in
the Dean show don't go anywhere
this is
this is the welcome back to the D show
and our special guests that I just
introduced listen 150,000 women has
testified to her helping their
relationship and as I stated she's a New
York Times best seller of her book and
she's been on Good Morning America The
Today Show CBS Evening News the the all
of these major networks featured and we
got her here on the D show welcome how
are you mrs. Doyle I'm great now use you
thank you so much now reading into your
books we see that your story is that you
started off you know getting married and
then it was just in shambles and you do
what people normally do they go to the
therapist and things just got worse yeah
they really do I mean one of the
problems that we were having early on is
that I thought there were just a few
things maybe just that everything really
I was so I was always giving him helpful
suggestions maybe how to be more tidy
how to be more romantic how to be more
ambitious at work and I didn't realize
that helpful and wife language is
actually critical at husband language
and my husband became very distant
withdrawn he didn't show any interest in
spending time with me and he's talking
to me so I was really lonely and I only
think I could think it was either a
divorce or marriage counseling but the
marriage counseling just completely were
complaining about each other for about
an hour a week and no couple ever got
happier that way so it really just
didn't work make things worse now you
quote a study UCLA study that prove can
you
tell us about this statistic now
psychology couples who received
traditional behavioral marriage
counseling were separated within one
year over over 70% of them are I mean
this is this is just not your opinion
these are facts by the professors of
psychology seventy at Seoul they did the
traditional thing that you you really
wanted to earnestly protect your
marriage you went to the counseling and
it didn't work but then you did
something that this is a proven
effective you even in business you know
you mimic the successful business
entrepreneurs and now 2/3 of them but
you actually that's what you did for
marriage people who had a successful
marriage tell us about this 15 years
plus you went and started to see what
they were doing right yeah clearly very
miserable we both were and so I started
asking women who'd been married what
seemed like an eternity to me which was
15 years because I believe been married
for six seven eight years at that point
now I've been married for 25 so 15
doesn't seem that long but at the time
they said things that didn't even make
sense to me I mean it was completely
contrary to everything I'd ever read in
Glamour magazine and I remember one
woman saying well I try never to
criticize my husband no matter how much
it seems like he deserves it and I
remember saying yeah have you got
anything else cuz I just don't think I
can do that it was kind of the opposite
to of what had been modeled in my home
but my parents are divorced so I was
following a failed recipe and I was
headed for the same outcome but when I
finally did get willing to experiment
with all these suggestions I made my
marriage like a little laboratory and I
just experimented trial and error I
spent years and something really magical
emerged there were certain things that
when I stuck to them it was like the man
who wooed me was the hack and his face
lit up when I came home and we were
laughing together again
we're holding hands again and if I
didn't stick to those skills then we
went back to wall to wall hostility and
Cold War's
and so I began to see a pattern and it
was really kind of amazing to me that I
had so much influence over the culture
of the relationship amazing let's get
right into the top three reasons now you
make this very bold statement again
backed by evidence that cop marriage
counseling ruins your marriage now let's
start with the number one the Rodney
Dangerfield dilemma talk to us about
this respect is so important for men
it's like oxygen in a relationship for
them and the very act of sitting on it
couch and telling a stranger everything
that's wrong with your husband all of
your complaints is really the most
disrespectful things you can do so right
there you're gonna be starting with a
deficit by taking the time to downgrade
your husband to degrade your husband to
a stranger right in front of him that is
profound I mean I tell people like look
try to breathe right now
try to breathe you can't but you're
saying something that's just so true you
know that is I mean I ask any man that's
what and sometimes women can't
understand that but now for him to
breathe you to breathing an oxygen for
him that respect is like oxygen and
we're better to give that love that we
women desire and need care about my
happiness and care about me and really
he was so busy defending himself from
all that disrespect he very much wants
me to be happy and every man I ever
asked thousands of them tell me the same
thing I'll say how important is it to
you that your wife is happy and they all
say the same thing they say it's very
important it's the most important thing
or it's imperative so as long as you are
respecting him he's gonna just knock
himself out
how about you probably heard this and
then sometimes the body language will
come into it with the little attitude
say well he don't deserve my respect and
so since all my experience is based on
being a wife and I only have that to go
on and you know I tried for a long time
to change my husband and that didn't
help me or get me anything that I wanted
in life it didn't make me happy what
I've learned is that I can only change
myself so that's where I start with it
with otherwise - I'll say well you can't
change him but you could change yourself
you could decide to be respectful and
see what impact that has on the
relationship it could just be an
experiment it's just like I did
experiments in my relationship and so
what's really mind-blowing for me every
time is with all these you know 150,000
women is when they change their behavior
he responds to them differently and all
of a sudden she's writing and saying oh
my gosh he's doing the dishes and he are
you got ability to do the dishes in
these he came to the gym with an
umbrella because it was raining he
didn't want me to get wet like I was
made of sugar so all of a sudden he's
back and he's doing all these romantic
sweet thoughtful things this is so
profound because there's a there's a
wise saying that when you when you
implement the things that you're talking
about with a man you will have that man
like a ring and your finger you'll be
able to move him around any way you want
but when you do the opposite the
complaining lack of respect you get the
opposite it's very true I mean I'm and
sweet and just oil and adorable my
husband is to me now we we were at a
breakfast cafe recently and I was just
kind of watching the people go by and he
goes oh don't move
and he got out his phone to take my
picture and he took my pictures like
look how beautiful you are and he hands
me the phone
and I started looking at the pictures
and they're all pictures of me this
photo right there's Laura making dinner
Laura working on her laptop and Laura in
the backyard and it's just it's so
moving I can't tell you the inner
strength I get from being loved
every single day best-selling author
here on the D show with techniques that
work that are proven and this can help
to benefit your life your marriage even
if it's in the shambles and you even
talk about even if people who they're at
the verge of divorce so we are at number
one we're going to get to two we're
going to knock these out on the top
three why marriage counseling can ruin
your marriage and what proven effects
work that you discuss in your book
we'll be right back with more here on
the Dean show don't go anywhere
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the Dean show with Laura Doyle
now you've been featured on some of the
major networks you have a best-selling
book tell us so after you went through
all this before we get back to the three
points so now your marriage turned
around and I mean this just went big I
mean a lot of people are catching on to
this it was really an amazing thing for
me when I first discovered these skills
and they were turning my marriage around
one of the things I learned is that
controlling my husband just wasn't very
effective so I couldn't control him
anymore so I just started controlling my
girlfriends and telling them hey you
should try this in your marriage you
know and I'd give him different tips and
we ended up having a little support
group in my living room and it was
really inspiring because there were five
of us and every time we would get
together they would have an amazing
story of something romantic or sweet or
that their husbands had done and it was
not like the things you've been doing in
the past at all so it really gave me an
insight wow this can work for other
people too and now that you know I've
helped over 150,000 women and 16
languages in 27 countries from a variety
of faith backgrounds what we've seen is
this is just universal that you know
women want to be loved and men want to
be respected and for a lot of us women
we didn't have any training on how to do
that it was almost like imagine if
you're 16 and someone just hands you the
car keys and says okay here's your car
just go ahead and dry now you're very
likely to crash that car without any
lessons on how to to drive I'm a right
did that when I was 14 I got in the car
and punch how hard can this be
and I knocked out the backyard fence so
but once I got some lessons everything
went smoothly and that's what this is
all about for me it's just learning
skills that helped me feel desired and
cherished and adored by my husband every
day for the rest of my life and that is
what every woman wants to be loved
cherished and adored and these things
that you're telling us now this can get
her to get what she wants I was looking
for this when I went to marriage
counseling that's what I was hoping I
was getting gay and it just wasn't there
you know that information I don't know
where we're supposed to learn this I
haven't really seen it anywhere else
let's get into we did number one the
Rodney Rodney Dangerfield dilemma let's
go we got two more
this is Kanye West's condition what's
this Kanye West's condition well this is
where at least for me I have a lot of
fear that my husband was gonna mess up
and it was gonna make extra work for me
or cost us extra money or I would be
embarrassed so I was always telling him
what to do I was always telling what
like what to wear to the party which
freeway exit you should take I was
telling them how to ask for a raise at
work and all this did was create just a
ton of tension and distance in that
relationship because my husband got the
message that I didn't trust him and I
didn't respect him either so it was
really interesting I mean the marriage
counselor told me that I was controlling
and I was like you know you're right I
want to stop what do I do it she's like
yeah I just stop being so controlling
and I had no idea how to do that and it
was really sad and frustrating for me
because I needed some some steps I
needed some guidance about how to do
that so that's what I've developed since
is this world-famous system for how to
relinquish inappropriate control of your
husband and focus instead on your own
happiness which really tremendously
improves the intimacy number-3 talking
about the dr. Phil phenomenon that you
state that no couple has ever gotten
happier complaining about each other one
week one hour out of the week you're
focusing on everything that's wrong when
we all have a choice every day to focus
on our gratitude and the Blessed
we have in our life or to focus on how
he you know left a milk glass in the
living room or left his sucks on the
floor you know some of these minor
things you know that he chews with his
mouth open sometimes right you can get
focused on that and forget that this is
the same guy that gets up with the baby
in the middle of the night or you know
works hard so you can stay home with
that baby or you know or watches the
baby while you go to Zumba class or
something like that so we all have that
decision to make every day marriage
counseling unfortunately it's really
geared towards focusing on the problems
there's one other problem I will tell
you I had a marriage mostly I just want
to kind of admit this in case there's
other women that relate to this and that
is I really believed that all the
problems in my marriage were my husband
I thought if he would change then I
would finally be happy of course I know
now that I know it works but I'm a
little embarrassed to admit that but
part of me taking him to marriage
counseling was about that like it was
kind of a hypocrite
I was just there so she can fix him I
was just being the dutiful wife standing
by while he got retrained somehow and so
that's not effective either that's a
setup for terrible disappointment this
is amazing this is like something I mean
when peanut butter was discovered I mean
this is like when the earth they thought
that they thought it was flab actually
round and you know when I guess the odds
and you know Society now it has one norm
but you I mean this is something that's
profound and really of great benefit
let's give or we go to break tell us you
know aphrodisiac this is something that
people look into for some foods as an
aphrodisiac some of these oils but you
you talk about something else being an
aphrodisiac tell us about this is
respect the minute her husband feels
respected she becomes so special she
becomes so desirable so beautiful and so
this is it's so funny I'll ask people
I'll say what's the number-one thing
that men want from their wives and
people always say sex and you know what
it's actually respect they want sex too
course they don't but respect is even
more important and for a lot of us webs
we just don't even realize when we're
being disrespectful I used to roll my
eyes at something my husband said and I
didn't realize I was being disrespectful
in that moment I would interrupt him
or he'd be trying to talk to me and I'd
be walking around the house maybe with a
laundry basket or something not really
listening and having no idea that I just
had no concept of what it looked like to
be respectful and now that I do I just
love that I can restore the intimacy so
quickly even if I mess up and I am
disrespectful I can apologize for being
disrespectful and it's like the wall
comes down immediately and we're back to
being close and connected again Wow
respect love formula for success we're
gonna take a break and I know there's
got to be skeptics to everything but
we're gonna also ask some questions that
the skeptic might be asking are you okay
with that okay beautiful be right back
here in the D show a best-selling author
Laura Doyle here on the D show don't go
anywhere
I want you to imagine you wake up and in
front of you are a bunch of guys running
around kicking a ball no goals no lines
no rules what would you think but is
that your life surely every sport has
its goal every game has its end it has
its objective it has its rules how about
life how about our life isn't there a
goal to life isn't there a purpose an
objective that we have to reach we think
so the Quran tells us that we exist in
order to worship God and worshiping God
means knowing God as the Quran says when
the hallux will Jinnah will insert
allure Leah badoon worship though is not
some narrow small thing its wide its
vast it encompasses everything that the
human being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either please
or displeasing to God the purpose of
life is to try and do everything in a
way that God loves and God is pleased
with that is your goal please subscribe
to the diva follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show a best-selling author
Laura Doyle tell us now there are some
people who have heard these three points
and they're like okay look marriage
counseling helps a lot of people you
know what why are you so against it we
went for years we spent over $9,000
$9,000 I really wanted to our
relationship we both day we're both
really desperate and as I mentioned it
didn't work for me but I assumed that it
was just us it must just be us there was
something about us that we just didn't
do well in marriage counseling but then
when I had this breakthrough discovery
of the six intimacy skills and I started
helping other women I became a
relationship coach and I trained other
relationship coaches all over the world
and one thing that became really evident
from listening to other women is they
often came to me after they've been in
marriage counseling they said yeah we've
been in marriage counseling for a year
and now we're separated or now we're
divorcing or now - was having an affair
and it was really I couldn't deny that
there was damage being done
I think if marriage counseling was
helpful of course that'd be great if it
was neutral that would be better but
what I've seen from my position as a
relationship coach is marriage
counseling actually does a lot of damage
so it's really important to me to get
that word out and let women know that
there is actually a proven way a way
that's done in real marriages in the
trenches and has worked for so many
people that you can restore your
marriage it's more fun than marriage
counseling it works faster and so so
it's really important me you know I it
gives me no pleasure to say that
marriage counseling is harmful because I
think marriage counselors are mostly
good people that really want to help and
unfortunately they just don't have the
right information just like I didn't
have the right information amazing now
someone who's a who is who's been going
to therapy or they are therapists
they've studied then they say look I I
have the the PhD in this area what
credentials do you have mrs. Doyle real
women and real marriages will heartbreak
and challenges and it really works and
we just see it you know women in
Malaysia and Egypt and Jordan and Spain
and South Africa and Mexico write to me
and say you know you say my marriage
thank you so much this is has been
really life-changing to learn this
information let's go before we end up
over a few more of these points you
talked about the use of spouse
fulfilling prophecies yeah tell us about
this what's go around you need to make
more money right you know you need to
just turn it you know what you gonna
race might shoot a better job and what
he heard me saying was you don't make
enough money and we got to the point
where he wasn't making any money he was
out of work and I was supporting us both
and I felt like in retrospect I can look
back and see how I created that with my
constant messaging so I learned about I
learned a few things about how I was
reinforcing what I didn't want instead
of what I did want and I decided to
change it up I started saying you've
always been a good provider which was
true and then just for fun because a lot
of this is about
I'm a part of why you why you get
married is to have you know good times
and laugh so I started calling him mr.
moneybags and around that time he
started his own business and he's had it
for over a decade now he's very
successful he works from home he loves
what he does and it was just a complete
transformation from before where he was
kind of struggling at jobs he hated and
he does a lot better now so I really got
to see how much influence my words have
and so I teach this to other wives now
remember one woman said her her spouse
fulfilling prophecy was you never want
to spend time with me that's what she
was affirming to him all the time and of
course it was manifesting in their
relationship so one day they were gonna
spend Saturday together and he got a
call from his buddy he wanted him on my
team so he said sure oppa mountain
biking she was really upset that he
would just abandon her like that even
though they had plans to spend the day
together and so the first thing I her
mouth was you never want to spend time
with me right her old affirmation but
then she remembered oh no I've got a new
I've got a new affirmation now so about
15 minutes later she went back and said
I know you want to spend time with me
I'm sure you'll work it out and so and
then she left the room again and five
minutes later he came back and said hey
I cancelled with Joe so that we could
spend our day together today so she was
just she fell out of her chair she's so
surprised how quickly it works to affirm
what you want sort of what you don't
want so wow this is a whole new
perspective now instead complaining just
doesn't work you are complaining to your
husband he actually can't even hear you
is what I discovered like if I come in
and say wow this house is such a mess
and no one ever helps me clean like you
just can't even hear it but if I find
the desire under my complaint every
complaint is actually a lazy desire if I
figure out what it is I'm wanting and I
focus on that outcome like I might
I would love it if the kitchen were
clean and my husband will say okay I'll
tell you I'll let the dishwasher you
wipe off the counters or whatever or I
remember one time you're supposed to I
want to make it dinner tonight but I
don't want to do the dishes and he's
like okay I'll do him and that was you
know I think actually was like 15 years
ago and he's been doing I'm ever since
so a lot hinges on the way I express
myself and just being really careful
that I'm picking the thing that I want
well we almost got a go I want you to
tell us where we can get the book and
now it's called some people also get
maybe someone who might get up in arms
and stayed the surrendering wife I'm not
surrendering to nobody it's a powerful
powerful and then you have another book
tell us about why you chose this topic
and this yeah this title for the book
and and where can people get it yes run
it to the creator yes it was just
acknowledging that I can't change anyone
besides myself and I'm not going to try
to change my husband but just be
grateful you know that he's the man that
I married and that I could just spend on
my days with and be connected to so I
think some people here you know obedient
wife or subservient wife and that's so
not it but you can get this around your
wife wherever books are sold but if you
want to come and read a free chapter
maybe take the intimacy skills quiz you
can go to Laura Doyle org and you can
sort of test yourself on those skills
and find out you know where you might be
lacking and where you can get some
better skills so so Lourdes Doyle that
or to find out more about the surrender
wife or you can buy our books your soul
let me just get one more out of you one
more this is this is interesting it's
like when you tell your husband when
you're forced and I'm telling them what
to do most likely he end up doing the
opposite is this true yeah if I was
trying to get into clean
garage I remember he even told me one
day he got up and he was sick and I'm
gonna clean the garage today and I said
to him hey you promised you were gonna
clean the garage today like I was
reminding him but I was just really
controlling true mad person and he said
you spent the rest of the day like just
avoiding cleaning the garage just
because I thought it was like he was
forced to kind of defend his own sense
of self and some sovereignty over his
own decisions for his life so that's not
where I want to be where I want to be is
maybe you know cleaning it together he
comes in and cleans it wants to show me
the good work he's done things like that
so that's that's how it is now can we uh
can we conclude the conclude with this
this is a true statement like both men
and women I mean we both need food and
water to survive right so poor for men
now the and we both want love and
respect but for the man the the water
you need more water to survive then you
can go more you can go longer without
food but you can go less without water
so the water for women is the love and
the water for men is the respect is that
correct that I am the more he just loves
me and thinks I'm so special and so the
more loved I feel and the easier it is
to respect him and it just goes around
and around like that that's amazing so
get the book surrendering wife and you
have the other one there they can get
also at your website what's the website
again sure Laura Doyle dot org so it's
not our G as an orgasm most people don't
know that that's what it stands for but
we're all about relationships here so we
cut lower joy of that orgasm thank you
so much for finding the time listen
we're gonna I'm gonna reserve you may be
in another few months we just touched
upon something I got so many more
questions I'm sure we're gonna get some
endless amount of feedback are you
willing to come back again on the
shoulders in the future thank you so
much mister thank you and thank you mrs.
Doyle for all of this insightful
information truly a benefit to anyone
who sincerely wants to better their
relationship in marriage and some great
advice and it's coming from a woman who
was also having a marriage in shambles
and she started to go towards people who
had successful marriages and taking
advice from them and now she's even
sought-after by marriage therapists who
are coming towards her 150,000 people
look women have credited her to their
successful relationship those numbers by
themselves I mean they tell a lot that
is amazing and now women by implementing
these things they get that what they're
striving for that cherishment adornment
that love that every woman wants but now
that's that aphrodisiac that she'll get
all these things by by giving that
respect to the man I mean a lot of times
people don't want to hear that but it's
the truth you know it's amazing to see
we see this complete balance in the
blueprint that we live by that the
Creator has sent down for all of mankind
that the woman is to give that respect
to the man and the man is to live with
his wife on a footing of mutual love and
kindness it's so clear and now to see
the best-selling New York Times author
speaking about the same things and how
its impacted not only her life but also
those hundred fifty thousand plus women
and it is the natural aphrodisiac to a
successful marriage if only we will heed
the advice
sincerely wanting to change because
change sometimes it's easier to move a
mountain but if we really want
successful lives to have a successful
marriage to live a successful life then
when the good news comes to you take
advantage of it implement it and this is
good news for anyone who implements it
that definitely they will have a
successful marriage thank you for tuning
in again
thank you mrs. Doyle for being here on
the Dean show subscribe if you haven't
already to our channel and look forward
to another exciting episode this month
is from
hope everybody is I told you we're gonna
bring you some special treats this month
and this was one of those so continue to
support the DS show and we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
please subscribe to the dgo follow us on
our official Facebook and Twitter pages
in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below